[Music]
to make each inlaid cabinet door a
woodworker clues the pattern onto the
wood making sure that it's perfectly
centered
[Music]
then using a router he cuts about three
millimeters deep making a groove along
the patterns perimeter and cutting out
the parts that will be inlaid with
mother-of-pearl
[Music]
meanwhile using another copy of the
pattern a worker makes templates by
cutting out the same parts the
woodworker routed out of the cabinet
door each template is marked either pink
white or green she glues it into a three
millimeter thick piece of the
corresponding color of mother-of-pearl
[Music]
the next craftsperson takes one piece at
a time and holding it steady with pliers
carefully sauce around the template with
the one millimeter wide blade once she's
cut all the pieces she reassembles the
pattern the next craftsperson spreads
adhesive paste into the cutouts in the
cabinet door then he fills each cutout
with its corresponding piece of
mother-of-pearl five hours from now once
the adhesive has dried
he runs a sander over the design to
remove the paper and excess adhesive
smooth the wood and polished the
mother-of-pearl
[Music]
then an artist h-his fine detail into
the mother-of-pearl this provides
texture dimension and expression to
objects and characters which until now
were merely blank shapes
[Music]